hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is
bonnie soy she is the author of a really
beautiful new book called
why we swim i loved it this is a
conversation about swimming of course
it's about
human beings relationship to the water
through survival
and community and flow and speaking of
flow
this conversation does just that i
really enjoyed it hope you do too so hit
that subscribe button and please enjoy
my conversation
with bonnie soy
[Music]
so nice to meet you thank you for doing
this it's such a pleasure i'm so glad to
meet you
i appreciate you coming down from
northern california and i'm so glad that
you jumped in the ocean today
like i said before we started i would
have been horrible you've been
disappointed right
thank you for our conversation about
swimming it was uh
it was one of those you know really
beautiful
sunrises i mean you kind of get jaded
living down here i think
in california specifically and
uh i paddled out this morning i took
photo and i sent it to a friend
who lives here and he said i think we
talked about it sort of like maybe
puncturing his like jaded heart
even even even uh even his after being
out here he could
well there's a lot of reasons to
complain about los angeles but the
beaches in the weather is not one of
them
when i see you know what i hear you
talking about surfing at ocean beach
like i
used to live in san francisco i'm like
oh my god so
cold and like unforgiving and uninviting
on some level compared to it is
it's like i think about it i like to
think about it as um
making a date to like go wrestling with
the ocean in the morning and i expect it
right at ob you always
expect that it's going to be somewhat
hellacious even on an easy low you know
baby day but um but i kind of like that
i kind of like
being challenged and i partly am
okay with it because um my my surf buddy
caroline paul
she's um she is one of the first she was
one of the first female firefighters in
san francisco
and so she's just like this you know
she's a pilot
she's just tough and she um has
basically had like
nine ten eleven twelve lives of
adventure
and she will go out and look stand on
the beach looking out
and every time she goes it doesn't look
that bad
every time no matter what it could be
you know
overhead double overhead and she'll just
say it doesn't look that bad and then so
we'll go we'll try it you know
we'll be repelled back we'll be you know
booted out of
uh the white water but uh i think just
like having that mindset is a good way
to be and i
and i like that about it kind of gets
easier the more you do it but it never
quite gets easy enough like the number
of times
you know i couldn't count the number of
times i've stood on
an outdoor pool deck in ridiculously
cold weather staring at the pool knowing
that the water in the pool is warmer
than the water in the air and still
being unable to
jump in that like that like moment where
you're just staring at it going how am i
going to get into this water
it's breaking the seal right you know
it's still the membrane it's like an
invisible membrane between you
right and it and yet
it's it i think that it takes something
it takes some activation energy to break
that seal every time no matter what
right but um it's always worth it right
yeah
always you're never like i wish i hadn't
done that yeah
are the pools still all closed up north
they
are s they've started to reopen so my
local pool
the albany aquatic center um sort of
just north of me in berkeley
um that's sort of my home pool and i
um it didn't reopen until very recently
right month two months and um
so i just ended up swimming in the bay
for the last eight months were surfing
did they
didn't they close aquatic park also they
did yeah
yeah they did because i think too many
people were going there in the beginning
and then they closed the dolphin club
and the south end rowing club the
facilities so even now
you know i have friends here and that
seems like pretty low risk
but i think in the beginning it seemed
right just the flaw
we didn't know enough right right right
so this the flocking together but now we
know of course
being outside great you know in the
water
ocean breezes great like keep doing it
survive get through this you know
there's a couple pools that are open
down here but they've all
migrated to these online platforms where
you have to reserve them
yeah you know you've been doing that
right i have but
i every time i look at i log in and
although
everything's booked yeah you got it i
never know
like i just like to go i'm like oh i
gotta i got an open hour i'm gonna go do
it like
it's difficult for me to know day-to-day
right so the other week
i like booked a lane every single day
at different times throughout the day
and i didn't make it once because there
were some
intervening you just weren't throwing a
bunch of things on the wall because it's
a long drive actually from my house too
and it's just you know i'm i'm
struggling with it um
i did the exact same thing that you just
did this morning you did because they
opened up and i said
i'm just gonna this one's open this
one's open i'll just you know
snatch it grab them yeah yeah sometimes
i show up
without a reservation just to see if
somebody doesn't show up because i've
missed so many i assume other people are
having the same issue
any luck i'm hit or miss
anyway um i'm so glad
to talk to you about my very favorite
subject swimming
and the human relationship with water
and this book that you created is just a
beautiful
work of art it must be incredibly
gratifying to
have it be so well received i mean
making the time 100
must read books of 2020. i mean that's
crazy right
as a writer if somebody's been writing
for a very long time
that's uh that's quite the accolade
yeah you know i of course um
i've been thinking about this book for
many years before i decided to write it
and and figure out how to
frame such a big topic right swimming is
is a topic it's not a
it's not a book it's not a story it's
not a narrative and i had to provide
that and i had to figure out
how to do that in a way that felt right
to me and to see it finally out in the
world and of course i could never have
imagined that it would come out into the
world
during a time when most people actually
couldn't go swimming right was
just very strange and um and then of
course the you know over the months i
mean it came out in april
the hardcover and then it will it came
sort of rolled out around the world
um in the summer and then well the
paperback will come out this coming
april but
to have then the gift of those months
where people
were thinking about their relationship
to swimming
in a way that they always had they'd
always taken it for granted
they'd never interrogated why it made
them feel good they would just
show up at the pool you know do their
workouts see their friends and go
basically did not enter their minds
because we didn't have to do things like
make lane reservations you know two
weeks out
to get some time with the water um and
to get these i've gotten the most
incredible letters from people
just i mean i
it's it's i would never have thought
that um
the book would get people to
swim in open water you know that wasn't
it wasn't i didn't have any uh
specific intentions yeah there's no
agenda there's no agenda exactly
it was meant to be this um you know this
cultural and scientific exploration of
our human relationship with water
and with swimming and how it's so
curious that we
um who we as a species
are not born knowing how to swim we have
to be taught that's a very interesting
thing of us
about us humans and about you know
higher order primates
right you make the point that we're the
only land mammal that doesn't
instinctively know how to swim yeah
and i've never really thought about that
think about i mean i once i
started to um look into this and i
um you know in the book i list examples
of you know dogs cats cats hate water
but they can swim
right bats can swim bats can do a crazy
like
butterfly it's insane yeah i look
look after we finish talking please
google youtube
[Laughter]
it's just um so we have this um
you know where we we came from the water
but we're not
suited to it anymore so we have to sort
we've been kind of clawing our way back
to it
as land animals and um
and and part of it is of course survival
but also it is so much more than that
once you learn how to survive the water
it can be so many things and that's sort
of how i laid out the book you know the
question
is presented in the title why we swim
and then
it's structured in these five thematic
ways we can answer that question
and i wanted to get at all that because
i want it to be this expansive
and really inviting um
an invitation to to come in the water
right and look at it
i took it to be very like sort of
um a swimming version of
chris mcdougall's born to run that was
like i joked with him about it that was
my goal
yeah meets uh there's a little bit of
murakami
you know what i think about when i think
about running it's like a swimming
version of that
wow the born to run thing but with the
born to run thing though
it would have been great if you found
some undiscovered indigenous tribe
somewhere of super swimmers that'd be
too that'd be too cool you know
too much now on the head right right but
it but it has that vibe it has that that
feel to it
and you know i'm somebody who's who's
passionate about the water and
somebody who's had a you know on a
personal level had a relationship to
something
from as long back as i can remember and
i've thought deeply about it and i've
written
you know snippets about it over time i
wrote my college essay about
youtube what it feels like to be like
underwater you know like
this is something i've been thinking
about for a long time but never
thought about what that might look like
in an expanded you know comprehensive
um version of and you captured it
perfectly like it's the perfect book
that
fires on all cylinders and it is this
weird like when you telescope up and
look at
humanity's relationship to water over
time like there's an anthropological
kind of aspect to your book
there's this push pull like we're drawn
to the water
you know coastal you know real estate is
expensive for a reason right there's
something about being by the water that
that
appeals to us on a very profound level
and we're also terrified of it and
repelled by it so it's that tension
that makes it interesting i really
wanted to get at that i mean i wanted
it to be a book that was not just for
swimmers
but for people who didn't don't call
themselves that don't think of
themselves that way and
why is that right it's because of this
tension that you speak of between life
and death
you know immersion submersion flotation
like
this this kind of i talk about in the
book this poorestness between states
that i think is like
it's the um it's what's so enigmatic
about the water and so alluring
and that we want you know we see of this
gorgeous sparkling body water we want to
get in it i mean kids you look at babies
like they just are just
in the bathtub you know they're just
enamored with it because it's
it is not of us it's not
for us necessarily you know we need
water to survive we need it
obviously but um when we see it around
us in our environment there's just
something that is talking to us on a
very
essential level and i wanted to explore
that a bit
so what do you make of that like what is
that
well i was really interested
to um you know in the course of my
research
discover that our brain activity changes
with the sound of water seeing water you
know
we know about how we respond to green
spaces right we
as humans just um are there are set
points in the environment that we
respond to i think there's a
great book by florence williams called
the nature fix and she talks about
how we are we are
evolutionarily um suited to respond to
certain set points in the environment
and that makes sense right so we
um you know being in the forest
being by the water and so
we have always known this on some level
right so
the books and you know philosophers and
writers
and um poets since time immemorial have
all spoken about
right you talk about the greeks yeah you
know you know
right and so once you start looking you
realize
it's everywhere it's everywhere across
time and so
i was very interested to know
um and wanted to to learn a little bit
more about the science that's starting
to catch up to explain why that is you
know how our bodies respond
not just um you know physiological with
emer
physiologically with immersion um and
with the mammalian dive reflex and all
that
um but that just being near water
not even getting in it looking at it
walking by it
smelling it listening to it um that
you know our our brain activity our
our alpha waves like you know increase
and that's
that's calm relaxation creativity i mean
that's good stuff and we know that
to be true yeah it's it's no mistake
that
images of sunsets at beach pages are on
meditation apps and
and you know there's something about the
the gestalt of the waves crashing
and the light bouncing off yeah you know
the surface
and the smell too that that produces
this
calming effect that can't be replicated
in other environments and i just know
personally
when you swim as somebody who runs and
rides bikes and does all
different kinds of things there's
something unique about swimming the
experience of that and how you feel in
the aftermath
of it that is very different and unique
and special
what do you think it is when you think
about it i think there's something about
the submersion and the muting of the
sound yeah or the sound of
what the waves you know what that does
in your ear canal
and and and the the sort of suspension
of gravity
and the the loss of feet like you you
lose your sensation of your limbs in the
same way that you
have on land like all of those things
combined to create
this um you know very different
experience that i think is
you know healing to the human body yeah
i mean just mind
floatation weightlessness an unburdening
i think is act is really what happens
physically
and mentally emotionally i think you
know you can't help but respond to the
medium in that way i think um
and there have been times i mean there
are there
you know the swimming in my life has
changed
over time i mean it has played different
roles but um
especially over the last year i think
about getting in water as
such relief like so profound from
this fire hose barrage
of uh badness in the world you know i
think just to have a momentary
um pause from that a relief
from that is just you know it is so
it's such a gift because it's so easy to
do
um and yet uh
not everyone does it right things to do
it and it's kind of the last frontier if
you want to get away from the phone
exactly yeah the noise and the stimulus
and it changes your perception and your
relationship with time
yeah it's uncomfortable if you haven't
done it before because you're like
wait you know i need to listen to music
or i need to you know like i i'm not
comfortable with not being over
stimulated and you kind of have to like
let that go
you are left alone with your own
thoughts in a way definitely that is
the worst right why would i do that why
would i do that whenever now there's
like these devices where you can
get underwater audio and they're
figuring that out and i'm like i don't
want to
yeah i don't want any part of that i
need to protect this place
is the one place where i get away from
all of that i think about you know
they've had
sort of somewhat crappy technology to do
that for a long time it doesn't work so
well exactly and there's a reason why
you don't
see people using them very often i mean
by and like i would say like
in a pool in any given day 98
of the people are not using anything
like that right i hope it stays that way
i know
well let's take it back to the beginning
i mean you know the obvious question is
like
you know why write this book like what
from whence
comes your deep appreciation and love of
the water
uh i mean i gotta go back to my parents
right by now i've talked about this
story
so many times but maybe you haven't
heard it maybe maybe
people listening might not have heard it
so this is the book tour
you answer these questions this is the
book tour that i got in different
directions but you gotta
i like this story so it's go ahead it's
a really good story
um my parents met in a swimming pool in
hong kong
and that's our family origin story and
it has
you know we when we were kids growing up
and um heading to the pool for swimming
lessons and my parents would be there
and
uh and then over the years we joined the
swim team and we became lifeguards and
it always people who came to know us
laughed when we told them that our
parents had men in swimming pool because
it was just
it was too perfect yes they did right
yeah there's that black and white photo
of your parents
they're quite young when they met they
were i think they were um i asked my mom
recently and i think
they were 18 19 something like that
i mean they're just gorgeous i mean they
just have the hots for each other
you know i just want to read all
happenings
because i see them you know and um i
hate to say this but that i have never
seen them so happy
this beautiful um
you know unfiltered i mean the both of
their smiles are so big
you know and uh and i
and it is a memory that i never had
myself
but i look at it and i like to think of
that as a time when they were really
happy
you know so my dad was a lifeguard and
my mom was at the pool
and um but when we grew up they were
always at the pool with us
or at jones beach when we would go in
the summers and
spending time together it's just very
much baked into
my brother and my experience of our
nuclear family because
until i was i guess in junior high
early high school my our parents were
together
ostensibly and then they my father
started
kind of they separated but we didn't
really know it as such
and so he started traveling back to hong
kong and then to china he's an artist
he's a
right you know he's i actually
for someone an emmy yeah he won an emmy
and
uh you know he and i were so close when
i was
when i was a kid um and
i was the one who accompanied him on
trips you know we i grew up in new york
and long island mostly and i would
go with him to client trips into
manhattan and we'd go
to the met and we would um just
i would spend hours with him in his
studio he would we were very close
and so i associate
you you were telling me about um you
wrote your college essay about swimming
i wrote my college essay about swimming
and art
and writing and those things were now
they think about it
uh they still are me you know they they
i knew from a young age that those three
things were
so essential to who i was certainly
it's it actually i was visiting my mom
this
summer back in new york and she made me
clean out the garage and i found my
college
essay and i thought uh it's very strange
to be looking back at this person
and understanding
what stayed the same many things stayed
the same you know essentially this
uh this relationship i have with the
water and also with writing and
creativity that's something that i
traced back to my dad
yeah very he was the permissive free
spirit
yeah absolutely yeah you know he was fun
and he was a kid and he's today at 73
years old he's still a kid
he's he he actually hasn't changed that
much but i have you know
was your mom more of the task master
then oh totally
yeah she was the strict one i don't
actually remember her smiling
it's terrible it's so terrible but um
you know after they divorced which was
really really painful they didn't
they didn't um finalize their divorce
until i was in college
and um but then i got to know my mom as
this
as who she was she was a person who was
not
in relationship to my dad she was fun
she had her own ideas
she was she had stories to tell
and um i that's when i got to know her
you know as a real person you need both
of those
yeah you know i think you need you need
the the artistic sensibility but you
need
the regimented person as well oh yeah i
uh you know she was the one who said you
know my my
my desire for order my desire
to prepare like all of those things come
from her
like my sort of risk
averse older person self
is because of her and i say those things
lovingly and
because i understand that those are
things that you need to
operate and be a responsible human in
this world
and i take the fun and the creativity
and the light from my dad but i also
know that
in the context of our family that all
that really ruined our family
this sort of shirking of responsibility
and
um and not owning up to that
so profoundly both
parents have shaped me to be who i am
and i hope you came out pretty good
oh thanks so it worked out you know it
could have gone terrible
harvard right like so but and yet you're
an artist so you have you know you know
how to focus and
you know organize your life but you can
also be a free spirit and creative and
you know follow these whimsical you know
passions that you have to track down
these stories
yeah that's um my mom
i remember my mom said to um a good
friend of mine
uh and it was not in a this was when i
was
22 and i took off
for a few months to go on a on a
fellowship to new zealand and i was
came back and i had student loans to pay
off and
i said i really want to work at this
adventure magazine you know they're not
paying me right now but i just
i'll just you know take a waitress
waitressing job or something in new york
while i'm doing it and she
she turned to my friend and she said
bonnie is such a free spirit and she it
was not a compliment
right now i was uh
but i said but you know what though to
her
credit like a couple of weeks later she
said you know if you really want to do
this
i will support you in this and i did i
did it for
six months and then i got a job that
paid money
actual money and and there we go
that was probably a big step for her it
was
actually now that i think about it
really was i have to ask her about that
if she
yeah but you grew up in and around pools
all the time swam competitively you and
your brother
but you didn't end up swimming in
college right you wrote
in college yeah i by the time i got to
college and i wasn't good enough to swim
in college
like not no i
but i was done with competitive swimming
because college to me represented like
something new like something super fun
and exciting and i always
knew that i was going to
um college was going to be the place
where i got to
meet new people and do new things and i
very much
felt that i wanted to do that because i
wasn't you know i
i think i was a very old person when i
was like a kid
you know i was like i want to be 20
and i'm eight something like that i just
just wanted to have autonomy i think
um and i rode crew
and i you know it was it's so
quintessential it's almost it's a cliche
to be like rowing
right sculling in the charts
yeah right it's like the iv is like
within sight as you're on the water
still a water sport though
it is um i want and i was talking to a
friend about this recently um
you know i love i just thought it was so
cool to have a different perspective of
water and when
you know when you're swimming it's so
solo right you're on a team but you
the experience of swimming is very much
you in the water and when you're in a
boat with
you know seven other people and you have
to
become one you have to move in unison
almost all of the time i would say like
98 of the time you you can feel like the
slight tug
of someone else who's not in quite in
your sink
and then the two percent of the time
when you are flying together
it's just so magical it's like it's
as if you are taking flight and you
didn't even
you're not trying and i was thinking
about this the other day because
i wanted i really loved experiencing
water
from a different perspective and then um
i only quit because uh
you know you're looking at me and i'm
not a giant person
you know and probably between like a
coxswain size and a lightweight rose
you're not small enough to be a cop i i
was
i was not uh i'm only 5'4 i was like
the the coach said to me
your technique is great i put you in
stroke in this boat
you know but you have to put on like
20 pounds and i had already packed on
like i was eating like a crazy person
you know in the the freshman dining hall
i was working out in the weight room i
was urging like a maniac and i just
was like i think i have maxed out i
don't
know that i can gain any more weight to
do them
it was weird it was just you were like
i'm done well then i joined water polo
oh you did okay again another water
sport yeah but it was fun i mean it was
it was hard i just
realized that um after a while that um
as playing a sport in college and you
know this more than anyone is
it's that's all you're doing yeah it's
pretty all-encompassing
and um i didn't want that you wanted to
broaden your
yeah aperture your horizons yeah i get
it
um what's what's interesting about your
relationship to swimming in high school
is that it the pool represented like
this refuge for you right like you had
you know a complicated relationship with
your peers in school but at the pool
which was a much more diverse you know
it was literally
a pool of all different kinds of people
right um it was kind of like a refuge
like a a place where you
felt at home and i think that's worth
exploring a little bit
and i really liked how you you did this
kind of archaeological dig
into the history of you know the united
states and its relationship with
swimming and in particular
you know pool building and access to
pools and how that changed over time
so let's talk about that a little bit
because i i think it's it's it's pretty
interesting i know
like i grew up in the northeast and
you know most high schools don't have
pools whereas in other parts of the
country they do
and that tracks back to our you know
sort of checkered relationship with
with race and segregation yeah i
i really did not appreciate meaning
i didn't understand um
the extent to which
the current um
[Music]
you know gap the racial gap in swimming
ability
between especially blacks and whites
in this country is so traced back to
um this era of segregation um
in our country and it that it the fact
that it persists to the degree that it
does
i mean i think the rate is that um the
latest statistics show that
um black kids are five times they drown
at a rate five times out of white
children
right i mean that is just
terri it's horrible and i um
you know then it's not just uh swimming
access and education but it's also then
when you break through
to join a team you find a team you're
swimming you love it
and then you feel like you're the only
one or you're the
you're you know swimming remains a very
white sport
um and you don't feel welcome or you
don't feel
um that you belong or that you have
positive images and and and stories uh
i i think that that that has a really
profound effect on whether you want to
keep doing something you know so like i
was i
recently got to talk to um the founders
of an organization called black hit swim
and um ebony roseman was the is the
founder and she was talking about how
when her daughter
started swimming um
and then i think the reason that they
started the organization is because when
they googled like black kids swim they
would they would
come up with um the the top google hits
were
like black people can't swim or black
kids don't know how to swim
when i was growing up as it as a kid
there was this trope like oh but you
know
black kids can't swim right they have a
higher density body density or something
like that like some crazy
reason why black people weren't good at
swimming
right it's just ridiculous and then that
is pervasive and it persists
and that's you know those are the like
ridiculous things that i heard growing
up too
um at the same time um i think
of my experience you know as you
uh pointed to was really special for me
because i
grew up i swam on a team that was in the
next town over
and it was a very diverse community
freeport new york is
you know has a large african-american
and a latino
demographic and it also the team also
attracted kids from all
across long island and you know even
though i was
at one of the you know the quote-unquote
the onlys in my high school
a town away two towns away uh that pool
was super diverse you know the head
guard uh
you know the at that pool where i
lifeguarded the freeport
rack was um was black you know and she
i don't know i think to see my point is
to be able to see representation around
you is no small thing i really
um credit that experience
with i mean making me who i am today
yeah
you know the uh the section in the book
where you talk about
this era you know in the 1910s and early
1920s when
america was building these massive
public pools right we've all seen
pictures of that extraordinary pool in
san francisco that just looked like
a football yeah i think there was one in
chicago too there were a couple
of these gigantic you know glass
ceiling you know like they look like
arboretums almost that were
gigantic that went the way of the dodo
right like they just disappeared yeah
they were
so this was a shift in um public pools
from being um you know during the
progressive area there were there were
pools for like
before that was public hygiene you know
like they were actually bathing
facilities so like working class and
immigrants
would go and men would go on alternating
days with from women
and um so so it was
much more a gender split
with these pools and then once they
became what you describe
these like pool palaces basically like
pools then public pools were then for
recreation
and so then were for families and were
then
um you know public authorities
you know that the sentiment was that
people of color could not swim in these
pools with white people
and so there were they were turned away
from a lot of pools
um there were um you know and then
during the civil rights era the
the public the pool spaces the watery
spaces the
even public beaches that they were sites
of protest
um and uh in the book i talk about how
there was this incident um called
a bloody sunday it was like in on a
public beach in mississippi and it's
it's where blacks went to
be you know to use this public beach
and and there you know there were riots
and and many of these
pools um that happened there was
violence um and
and if you think about it we're talking
about how water is freedom water is
relief water is
so universal to all of us as humans and
yet
this essential um
this essential thing was not available
to everyone um
and and i think the right of leisure the
right
of recreation was something that was was
seen as
um symbolic of this fight for equal
rights and equity
yeah and so ultimately these pool
palaces
close down they just shudder right and
then hence begins
this movement towards the backyard pool
so the public pool
kind of you know isn't a primary focus
anymore because it's complicated for
those reasons
yeah after desegregation you know you'd
think that
the fight is you know is over you know
equality won but actually um a lot of
whites
then you know of means like fled
the public community rules and pull you
know
built their own um backyard pools and
you'll see this you know in california
it's interesting right because
california
especially southern california is such a
an epicenter for this backyard pool
culture and it's this beautiful i mean
you look at these photos of like palm
springs and la
and um it is such a
it is this very golden light um perfect
um visual history and yet where are the
black people you know where are the
people of color in these
records and um and i think that that
that is being rewritten and and pushed
at
and and you know that that uh beautiful
bubble is being punctured
um in a way that is um starting to be in
in in a way that is really important to
our understanding of what those images
actually meant and met exclusion
right it feels it feels like
there's still some way to go though
because oh yeah the country is littered
with these public works pools that are
all over the place
many of which sit drained right and
empty like that pool
in central park at the north end of the
park that massive pool like most of the
time there's no water in that pool like
there seems to be
a lot of um establishments like that all
over the place that either
because they lack funding or for
whatever reason
that i'm unfamiliar with they just don't
they they're not really
you know they're like in disrepair yeah
it's really expensive
to maintain a pool and um what i learned
in
this pandemic period i was reporting a
story about a reopening of a public pool
in my neighborhood and i learned
that most municipal pools you know the
public pools that are run by cities
uh operate at a deficit even in normal
times
so they're hemorrhaging money and the
the season in which they would take in
revenue is
the summer you know camps and um
all like swimming lessons and swim teams
and for this entire year they
they did not have any of that and so now
they're even more in the hole
and so now as as many
pools have struggled to reopen in some
limited
fashion right so but think about it it's
one lane
per person uh spaced out if they were
losing money before
yeah i hate to think about what it
means because um the sad fact is a lot
of these pools
um will not reopen you know even after
the pandemic and
so that to me is
i mean it's hard to stomach because that
means then another generation of
of kids might not get right what we had
you know
um and that's just really it's hard i i
think
about you know in in the course of
researching this book
uh i learned that swimming education is
universal it's part of the public school
education in so many other countries and
i think
that would be amazing you know if that
were the case right in this country it
would make
such a difference but but you need
adequate pool access to do that and most
schools
you know don't have pools or don't have
a pool that's proximate enough
or is accessible it just comes it's it's
a really
huge funding issue but i i just think
about these
you know in iceland you know there's
every town has a yeah
a pool every town i know tiny tiny town
of like a hundred people has a pool
well let's talk about iceland because
this is a big part of the book it's
super fascinating i mean first of all we
should mention
you you said at the outset that you
broke the book up into these
various sections survival well-being
community competition and flow
which kind of cracked the code for you
and helped you figure out a way in like
how do you write a book about swimming
like
it's just like this ethereal amorphous
thing
right but kind of planning your flag in
these various categories provided you
with like some footing to do this
a big part of the book or the the early
part of the book
is about iceland and in particular this
one fisherman whose name there's no way
i'm going to be able to pronounce
but i've never heard of this guy before
and it's an unbelievable story
i will tell you about good looker frit
thorson
how long did it take you to figure out
how to let that roll off your tongue
with ease
it's it's been some time many years
um say it one more time good looker fred
thorson
but the thing that we have to know is
that his nickname is laurier
and everyone calls him that so i will oh
yeah henceforth very good
call him lawyer because that's way
easier um so i opened the book with the
story because how could i not right
um it's a story that my husband told me
one night and he'd heard it from you
know he works in
with fisheries and the environment and
oceans and um
i think he'd heard it from an icelandic
friend and
this story is famous in iceland because
in 1984
um there was a fishing vessel that
capsized off the coast of iceland
and um good looker for thorson lloye was
the ship's mate
and he was like he was 22. he was super
young
um but it was the the fishing trawl
caught on the sea bottom and then and
then it overturned and everyone got
thrown over board and everyone's in the
water holding on to the boat's keel
before it starts sinking
and you know this is bad news it's 41
degrees
water it's freezing it's the middle of
the night
and they are you know they are unable to
deploy the life raft and the sad thing
about is that
they were supposed to um the
self-deploying life rafts had become a
sort of
thing fairly recently at that time and
and they were supposed to have installed
that in the boat but they hadn't done it
yet
so this boat is thinking and the you
know the few
of them on our left are holding on to
the keel and then they say you know
we're going to start swimming
captain and and lloyd and so they start
swimming
and pretty soon he's the only one left
was there a lighthouse like how are they
finding theirs
okay yeah so but it's six
km at least six kilometers away right so
he's um
it's the lighthouse on this island which
is off the coast of the main island of
iceland it's called heimei
and it's part of um the vesmaniar
archipelago i've been practicing yeah
you got that down
the westman islands um but he so he saw
the light
house the light from the lighthouse and
he started swimming and he's just
swimming swimming and swimming
and he's wearing like a flannel shirt
and jeans
you know in a sweater right that part
confuses me because
i would just take that off like that's
holding you back
i can't remember what the i mean he
certainly lost his boots
but he's swimming and um you know he's
talking to seagulls
and he and it's it takes him six hours
six hours six kilometers and he gets to
shore
now the thing to understand about this
island is that it is
a volcanic island like all of iceland
and
i think it was ten years before that
there was um a volcanic
eruption that had resulted in like the
island got bigger by like 20 percent
but then there are also these like sheer
100 foot cliffs
and like very spiky lava fields
so he gets washed ashore at the base of
one of these hundred foot cliffs
so he gets there and he cannot get out
there's no way for him to climb so he
has to get back in and start swimming
so he swims around to a place where he
can finally get out and he's walking
across this
lava field and he's
you know his feet are bleeding because
it's really sharp and he like there's a
frozen
um uh a sheep cistern it's like a
tub of water that feeds waters the
animals and he like punches through
because he's so thirsty you know he's
been out there
for hours and hours and then he trudges
into town
and you know i think day is breaking and
there's like a light on the first house
and he like walks up to the house and
there's like bloody footprints behind
him in the snow
and it is just insane because then
they're like i cannot you know
they rush him to the hospital they can't
they can't discern his like heartbeat i
mean it's like very faint and his
or he's like they can't really read his
body temperature but he has
no signs of hypothermia so like
you and i yeah that's crazy 20 minutes
max yeah
41 degree water we would be dead
everyone else
everybody would die and then how long
was the trudge in the time
i can't remember what the air
temperature was but it was significantly
colder than that
um and he
you know they he's just a little
dehydrated
he's fine um and he's they keep him
in the hospital for observation and it
turns you know and it's not
for some time when they have done some
um
research and studies that he's taken
part in but he has this
um the reason he was able to survive
okay a he's a very good swimmer
everyone nice on swims he was trained to
be as such as a sailor
um and he has he's like a seal
his fat is two to three times normal
human thickness he's it kept his
you know core body temperature is he a
fat dude he's a big guy
he's six for i don't know how much he
weighs
but at that you know you you can see
photos of him from that he's not
unusually
gigantic but he's he's a solid guy
but you think about plenty of guys who
are really
big who would die very quickly in you
know
water that cold it's not it's not about
the fat but certainly the quality of the
fat
right the quality or where the it is
subcutaneous in the right places
to protect the organs yeah it's crazy
right so he becomes
this massive hero and also a science
project for
a lot of people yeah and he he
he gets so much media attention that it
kind of compels him to become this
recluse that's right um
and so you can imagine that um when i
came across the story i thought
this is i gotta talk to this guy because
it just is so compelling and i know that
he doesn't
um you know he's told this story before
but has been a really long time since he
talked to journalists
but of course the first thing you find
when you google him is
that this happened to him and then also
that he doesn't talk to entrepreneurs
what what soured him on the whole thing
he told me um it just he felt that his
story was being
um misrepresented and you know of course
he started to feel harassed right so
like his friends died
yeah it's it's horrible you celebrated
for something that's quite tragic
yeah and i think at a certain point you
just want to live your life you just
want everyone to leave you alone um
and it kept kind of coming up and coming
up and
and to be honest though i i mean i want
to i want to point out that
he was very vocal in the first years
after
um the accident because the conversation
they had on the boat's keel was like
and he told me this later on um was if
someone
if someone makes it they have to tell
and he said you know
nine times out of ten actually nine
point nine times out of ten nobody
survives this and so they don't know
what happened
and he said i was the person who could
tell
and so he was advocating he spent quite
some time advocating for
for the mandatory yeah
like self-deploying life rafts and you
know they have the swim every year in
his honor for like
you know the last thirty five six seven
odd years um called goodluckson
which means good lookers swim and it's
everyone it started out as something
that the navigation college did you know
all the sailors
did with their clothes on to but in a
pool right in a pool absolutely yeah
because
everyone would die so that what's the
point right
i know they breed them strong and nice
but you know very hard
they're not that crazy but it's
interesting because he became
this symbol of icelandic resilience
right it's
it they embraced him
and that story and the you know honoring
him with the tradition of the swim
because
to icelanders as a people like this is
this is
what he's like the epic symbol of their
survival resilience you know
um and so he
accepted that mantle but then after a
while just
you know he's he's a very um
well so i i really it was hard for me um
to figure out then how can i approach
him
in a way that's right how are you gonna
engender trust from this guy who's been
burned by the media and
wants to be left alone right there was
you being the dutiful
journalist i did you play that you play
the long game
i played the long game well there was a
movie i guess um
not too long after i found out about his
story there was a movie by this like
blockbuster icelandic director um
cormacker i think is his last name
baltista he like did um
uh some everest movies i think with like
denzel washington or oh really uh mark
wahlberg and denzel
he's directed these like big blockbuster
movies
and he but being icelandic he was
obsessed with the story of
good looker fred thorson and and when he
i guess he was a teenager when this
happened and he said
you know i this to me is the story this
is like the adventure
story it's like um
what does it mean to be a person and
spec in the sea and and what drives
someone
right and so he they approached the
producers approached
um lawyer about the film and he was just
like
you know i think at this point he was he
had kind of things that quieted down he
was starting to
live a life that was more to his speed
no
he has grandkids he has kids he has a
you know why he
he works you know he still works in a
fishing
for um a fishing uh company and um
he was just like make the movie when i'm
dead like i don't want any part of this
so
but they made the movie they made it
anyway he made it anyway right
and his he felt betrayed he felt
betrayed and his
you know to hit um you know he lives in
a very small town on a very small island
in a very small country you know
everyone knows him
the town you know protects him
um but people so i was just like okay
how do i
how do i follow my
you know sort of storytelling instincts
and also i respect this person as a
human
i respect his desire for privacy what if
i
write him a letter so i wrote him a
letter i wrote him a letter and then i
ran it to a google translate into
icelandic
and then i mailed it but but you can't
pitch right so what's the just you know
i appreciate you like what is the letter
i think i said um
i said i i think i told him that i was
i was working on a book about swimming
and i knew about his story
and that i would love to just talk to
him about
what swimming means to him i wanted to
hear from him in some way right so
he he wrote back almost immediately but
he said no
right and then i thought oh that's
oh that's so disappointing but then
we started to have this like pen pal
relationship
and we just and i remember my husband
and said like you could just write to
him and see what happens you know just
so we started because there's something
about his opening message to me
that seemed to leave the door open a
little bit
he just said something about you know i
have not had
great experiences in the past with
journalists it has something to do with
your project
but he said something in that email and
i'm trying to remember what it was
um like if you the message being sort of
if you can prove to me that you're
trustworthy
not in so many words but yeah i got the
sense and um
so i just kept writing and and i would
send him
you know little bits of trivia or
when i was in japan you know doing some
research i would send him a photo from
there and
because he i think he said that he um
he said something about swimming saving
lives and
uh and that was and he used emoji
i thought would he use emoji if he
wasn't leaving the door open a little
bit
i don't know it was interesting yeah so
i just persisted
and then i didn't meet him in person
until
a year later
and i still like to the day that we
actually met in person i did not know if
he was actually going to see me
right but you go out to iceland i go to
iceland
you end up getting an audience with him
and the guy ends up being like your
buddy
he is this wonderful funny
um he loves jokes storytelling like he's
just um
a very endearing guy and he actually
you know we got to the point where um he
he he trusted me with a story and then
he
um very quickly you know he had an
interest in my family and we
we went oh my god now it seems so long
ago
the summer of 20 last year 2019. we went
to the pharaoh islands and we went to
iceland to see him
and um you know he he
and his wife being very experienced
grandparents like they just
had all these snacks on the table for my
kids you know they just and my kids
adored them because they were just like
can we go visit laurie maria again
like again and again and again and to i
mean yesterday my son told me he said
can we go back
there um and you know on chris on
christmas
you know he sends a he sends me a text
with a photo because he looks like
hemingway cross with santa claus now
that's kind of exactly how i
would envision him he sent a photo of
himself
in a santa suit and said i think this
guy says he knows felix and teddy
i mean it was hilarious like he's he's a
great guy
that's cool but what did he tell me i
mean he
he told me his story but also i what i
realized is that um
so much of what his story means is what
other people
say about him what he means to them
so i tried to do this kind of twinning
effect of like telling
both stories at the same time
because it is about the stories we tell
ourselves yeah
and on some level it's his story
but it's the national story right right
and he's gotta release that and allow
people to have their own experience
with who he is and what what he endured
yeah
i think that's right but this kind of
opens
the book up to this you know kind of
dialogue about
not just human survival in the elements
and in water but
also the unique properties of cold water
and human exposure to cold water and you
talk about brown fat like converting the
white fat to the brown fat and all the
new
studies that are you know going on right
now about how cold water exposure
extends longevity and you know is
healing
to the body right um
one of the studies that i looked at
showed okay so you're you know warm warm
water versus cold water right so
i think it was like an hour immersion in
90 degree water is like
very comfortable very relaxing
um you know reduction in pain you're
just like you're very
it's like it has positive effects on
your body and our
same amount of time in like 56 degree
water or something like that it was like
dopamine levels through the roof like
metabolism revved up
like feelings of um euphoria
you know i mean and it is uh you know
and just like
very alive wellness kind of
you know things that are measurable but
also things that you experience that are
very acute no reduction in inflammation
of course
um and i just think uh it's so
interesting
um you know the way it it speeds up our
metabolism it's actually like
on its face cold exposure is not that
great for you right so
like cardiovascularly it's like terrible
it's it just like jacks up your
blood pressure very quickly at first
and then over time you actually it
lowers your blood pressure because it's
just
your your heart and your blood vessels
are then
able to handle it over time within a
single session
or with repeated exposure with repeated
exposures
yeah so um you know we talk about
uh where the the sort of longevity um
scientists i talked to hiro tanaka he
was talking about how he went to japan
back to japan where he's from
and he studied the ama right so those
freediving
uh grandmas really like you know they're
they're
all diverse pearl divers um you know
diving for shellfish
um and they a lifetime
of cold water exposure right their
cardiovascular um their
ability their cardiovascular health is
amazing
um their hearing is terrible
because the cold water really destroys
your hearing
but they um they're you know he wanted
to know about
um the you know their
like how were their arteries you know
were they flexible
or had they you know was it like
was their experience um over time
had that made them something a little
bit more akin to
um a marine mammal you know just like
how they're
able to um you know cope with
with uh the water and he found that they
were
like they're just their cardiovascular
health was really great
um and you know
i i think they live to be quite old you
know
and um the traditions i think that
there's been renewed interest in just
again like
these people who um
hue to a traditions
and are able to do things that we
wouldn't imagine doing
you know in our modern day and they're
not dying yeah
heart disease right yeah um
and and that you know he the he uh here
at tanaka also did research with
arthritis you know and and cold water
and swimming and
what i was really interested in was that
the
swimming practice uh
lessened the effects of arthritis you
know from a pain perspective from an
inflammation standpoint from a mobility
increased mobility and those effects
lasted for much more much more
time beyond the actual time in the water
and so it's just like
it the benefits are are are um
enduring and i found that really
compelling yeah that's super interesting
yeah so your way into this cold water
world
quickly becomes our mutual friend kim
chambers are right
who who's a looming figure throughout
the book like
she's you know other than yourself like
almost the primary protagonist
throughout this i mean how could she not
be i know well she's larger than life i
mean she's just
i just i love her so much and i just
think the world of her she's amazing
but she brings you down to the the
dolphin club and
introduces you to the whole aquatic park
the whole
ecosystem exactly that's that's exactly
what it is it's an ecosystem
and it's a very explain what that is i
used to live around the corner from
there so
i never i mean i've swam in aquatic park
many times and i swim from alcatraz and
all of that but i was never like a
member of the
dolphin club i only know a few of those
people i know veto and yeah
yeah people but it's a i mean
so the dolphin club and the south and
rowing club um
they've been around since the late 1800s
they've
they share an actual building you know
but they're
clubhouse rivals yeah they're rivals but
they're friendly rivals and they love to
trash talk
and um and and they are very much
uh the the members are
like diehard bay swimmers cold water
swimmers
most of them you know take pride in the
fact that they
don't use wetsuits do it year round and
have
this i mean there is a celebration of
like the hardiness the vigor
the um you know how long to stay in and
right you know and uh cool to go and
swim in aquatic park in a wetsuit
well you can't you do you know what the
first time i did it i was
cute right i was afraid i was gonna get
ridiculed but you know people were very
nice to me
but they just said you can't bring your
wetsuits into the into the clubhouse
yeah they said leave them outside i'm
like okay uh
it's almost like um you know when the
wet wetsuit
like there's like a there's a line
that's like a no
no passage through the space no wetsuits
into space
uh but so it's this
and it's all ages like all body types
um it is amazing to me that um
that there's this community there it
still amazes me
and i've seen it and it's just beautiful
and so kim
you know kim's the first woman to swim
from the fairlawns in san francisco
she is the sixth person to the ocean
seven and she did all of this
um after almost i mean i think all of
your listeners
will probably be familiar with her story
but that she almost lost her leg to
amputation after this
accident um where she fell down the
stairs and
she it took her two years to relearn how
to walk
she was embarrassed about her scars and
part of the rehab was like you know
maybe swim
you know and she by her own description
was a
horrible swimmer when she started had
horrible technique
and then one day she's invited by a
couple of guys at the pool to
to swim at the dolphin club at aquatic
park
and she said this is a i love the way
she describes this she
she describes um
her you know not she says not many
people have a
visual record of their rebirth and she
said that they happened to
like video her that day when she got on
the water and started swimming
and she said like you know here's this
like broken
skinny like um 120 pound woman who's
just like
um has been through hell and and is like
the biggest eating granite on her
face and she's in this water and she
feels so alive and she feels so
um she feels reborn like it literally
was her
it started this completely new life for
her
you know as a marathon swimmer as a
freakishly accomplished marathon swimmer
and i think
a large part of that of course is that
she is
a very resilient person yeah
um she also talks about how she has a
very very high pain threshold which has
gotten to
her into a lot of trouble you know well
i mean the whole thing with her leg when
she fell down the stairs
that day she kind of ignored it she
ignored it and she drove to work and
then her leg was like
twice the size and then she passed out
and then she got to the hospital and it
was like
you you know all that swelling was
killing all the nerves in her leg and
they almost had to
you know amputate her leg and so she
laughs at it
and again of course then that pain
tolerance
um of course allows her also to do
extraordinary things
yeah um and
she also had uh about with a couple of
bouts with
guillain-barre right um that's more
recent
more recent yeah how is she doing now
she seems to be doing
um pretty well we talked um
recently a few weeks ago a couple weeks
ago and you know she's swimming
you know during during the pandemic
she's she's back in the bay
swimming um and she's trying to knock
out the seven summits also right is that
did that get
tabled for that was her big
goal i think when and that really was i
mean she was
she was well on her way when gambere
happened to her um and i don't know if
that's something that's still on the
table right but she wanted to be the
first person to do
both of those things yeah nobody's ever
done that have they
don't get any ideas people
but what's you know even additionally
compelling about her is not only her
her you know love for cold water like
she took to it immediately
her freakish uh you know endurance
capacity
but also this interesting relationship
with fear because she swam
from the fairlawn islands you know to
san francisco
you can't see anything like i just it
sounds like my worst nightmare
it is pretty much everybody's she's like
oh she thought it was fun you know
like it's you know so that's a thing on
top of all of this that
makes her separates her i think right
the fear
i mean she'll be the first person to
talk about um
[Music]
how she was afraid so many times about
um you know like people seeing her scars
you know that's one thing i mean just
that she had changed so much
from that person who fell down the
stairs that day um
and then over the course of becoming
this swimmer and then
um you know breaking these world records
and um
then coming to this point where she
wanted to make these swims bigger than
herself right so then
turning her attention from her own
struggles
outward to say okay if i have a voice
what can i
use this for and she did that curly
breeze swim
the red sea thing no the one well that
one too but the one across the border um
oh right in mexico yeah
and that you know she did that with uh
mexican swimmer
antonia aguias and they were like the
ambassadors
you know across the and it was really to
call attention to
all the deaths of the border you know it
was she she kept saying that it wasn't
she didn't want it to be political she
wanted it to be about life and caring
about life
and she said when they swam across and
got out the beach in tijuana all these
uh school kids were on the cliff wearing
the colibri t-shirts
and cheering and she's like it was this
it was like wanting to use the swimsuit
as a way to bring people together and i
and i really
i i i so admire her for
for all of the you know this evolution
that she's
gone through in her life i mean she
always talks about how it's hard for me
to um
imagine this but she said she was a
really shallow person like before
all of this really yeah you can't
imagine it right she's like this glowing
light yeah yeah um
but something got activated in her
something got activated you know
and in the venn diagram of these various
buckets or categories that you've
divided the book up into
you know she overlaps you know survival
with
community yeah for sure yeah she is that
bridge
because um you know not just the healing
part
but the you know she survived so many
things in her life because of swimming
and then what and swimming was the thing
that kind of brought her back from both
her leg injury and then from
guillain-barre
and um was a way for her to
rehab her life she really did do that um
but it was through this amazing
community at the dolphin club
and i i think about i remember being in
the locker room there
the locker room and that's something
that i super miss
in this time like the locker room at the
pool right the post swim
just like the chatting and the secrets
and the
um and you're you're in everybody's you
know intimate space but i don't know
what it's like in the men's locker room
actually what i want to ask you about
this
because it's not i mean at least from my
perspective
it's like this i think kim has described
the dolphin club sauna as like a hen
house like everyone's just
sharing like you know stories of
like illness or boyfriend troubles or
um things that they're struggling with i
don't know what it's like
on the other side well it's changed with
different phases of life yeah you know
but i think
the the unifying principle is that when
you complete a swimming workout
you're kind of it's like this pipe
cleaner for your mind and your soul
right like you
emerge from that experience like feeling
very grounded and
and also open right so then when you go
to the like you know like listen when i
swam in college everybody goes into the
hot showers and
is in there forever right you just quit
take a quick shower and get dressed like
you you stay in that hot shower as long
as possible and there's
a lot of you know yeah there's a lot of
conversation that goes on there and even
in
master swimming it's the same for sure
um i mean i don't know what the women's
locker room is like but like yeah
there's a lot of you know bonding and i
think
yeah it's it's different with men
because men you know are
are um it's harder to get men
to you know have kind of intimate
conversations with their friends and
their peers but there's something about
that locker room experience that's
conducive to that
in the wake of just enduring like a
difficult workout together
you know maybe it's the same in track
and field or any other sport i don't
know
but yeah um it's certainly you know a
tight-knit
bond that you have with those people
that you know you do this hard thing
together and even though it's individual
you are doing it as a collective right
you're doing it
you're doing it apart together yeah yeah
yeah that makes it interesting
um well let's talk about the uh the
well-being component of this because i
think there's a lot of people listening
who either
are swimmers or people who are perhaps
intrigued by the idea of maybe getting
into cold water for the first time or
you know trying to learn how to swim
when they didn't learn as a kid
there's so much well-being to be mined
from
this sport or just this activity i mean
i i also want to you know we talked a
bit about the
physical and physiological benefits
right of
immersion but i also want to talk um
you know a big part of the well-being is
the flow right it's the flow state it's
it's where your mind goes um
[Music]
when you're doing it and i think again
what's so
interesting about swimming and makes it
unusual and unique
in the sort of sports world is that you
are um you're alone
you're in your head a lot your senses
are
muted um you're not really
talking to someone else i mean even if
you're doing a workout together
even if you're doing a long swim
together with someone you know in the
bay
or in the ocean or whatever you're
you're not chatting the way you would if
you were
going for a long run together and so
your
um your awareness i mean i think it
depends on
okay so i i want to talk about two
things like pool swimming is super
different from
open water right so in a pool what's so
great about
that is that it's this very known
circumscribed every the distance is
known your body is it knows where to do
the turns and
you know you you can your mind is freed
in a way
that is different from open water
because open water you
have a sort of acute nowness yeah um
yeah a little bit of hyper vigilance yes
in open water yeah
um and
even if you're someone like lynn cox or
kim chambers and you're
swimming for like a ton of time
like just so long
you are still attuned to what's going on
in your environment in a way that's like
again you're attentive to dangers um
potential dangers although your crew is
probably let's be doing that
but when you're out there i mean you're
i find that when i'm
swimming in the bay i'm constantly
scanning
you know it's this you
can't really stop yourself from doing
that even if you know of
this place um there's still some alert
you know and i think that then then the
acuteness and the presentness of being
in the water is like
again like taking you out of that your
head and all the that's going on
outside of that like i think to be to be
forced to pay attention to that moment
right you're just compelled to be
in the moment and present yeah and you
have for that
hour or 45 minutes or whatever you have
forgotten about
just everything all of the things that
are
holding you down are occupying
preoccupying you
and you know right now there's plenty of
that yeah
um but i mean actually i i just realized
like
in this conversation with you the way a
great conversation can
take you out i haven't thought about
covet for a while right
so thank you for that okay you know like
i gave you a one-on-one
yeah i really appreciate it yeah but
just but i'm distracting you
right but to be you know so that you
know being in open water
is a i don't want to say distraction
because distraction sounds
negative like distraction sounds like um
it's not quite the right word because it
seems like it's something that you
shouldn't be
focusing your attention on but it
compels your focus in a way that i think
is super useful and um again it's a
relief it's
it's it's a it's a breath away
from the rest of everything
right your normal state of being your
normal
um land self
um and then in a pool it's i find it no
less um i know a lot of people don't
love swimming in pools
but i really love pools i do too and
when people say it's boring i i don't
find it boring at all there's something
about that
constriction like how can you stare at
the black line the whole time but
because you know exactly how long the
pool is and you know that your
environment is static essentially
that gives you the opportunity and safe
right that you don't have to
think about it right and it allows you
to like live in this
state of presence but also kind of that
and you talk about this in the book as
well like
this liminal state right where you're
not you're not you're not on land
you're not under water you're kind of in
between and
there's something about that that place
puts your mind
in a in a place to problem solve or
you know to be in this active meditation
state
and that's very related to the breath of
course and you talk about that in the
book as well like
the regulated you know inhaling and
exhaling that comes with that
that you know has some impact on your
you know
sympathetic nervous system in a certain
particular way
you're allowed to wander i mean you're
allowed to make connections and things
are floating around
and you they're they're not tethered
in the same way i think that um again i
come back to the quality of the medium
it's like there are
things don't have to be connected in the
same way at least for me
i have i have interrogated myself many
times over the writing of this book when
i'm swimming like what the hell am i
thinking about
how am i thinking about these things and
um
you know i wrote a great amount of the
book in my head when i was right i'm
sure
because i had well i'm sure you get
stuck you go swim and then
by you know not focusing on it you
are allowed you're able to free
associate and solve that problem so that
when you or you're in the locker room
afterward you're like
i got it i think that's the um i love
that term the
the soft fascination right there's
something that's
um holding our attention but not too um
closely so that you're able to
um do that free association that you're
talking about
which is so great yeah and it's you know
it's different from running like running
is analogous i suppose but the
experience isn't quite the same
i mean for some reason definitely not
for me i don't know
i mean i love running too but the
feeling that i have afterwards is
different
yes different yeah certainly swimming
makes me more tired and definitely more
hungry i was so hungry
i don't know why do you get so hung and
also
talk to me about this when i s
after a swim workout i have to pee like
400 times
i cannot stop what is going on that
doesn't have to be running
it's weird right i think yeah it's got
to be having to do something about like
the hydrostatic pressure or something on
your body
that somehow then you're like every all
the water gets forced
i literally have to go to the bathroom
like ten times over two hours
if there's someone listening who knows
why this happened please email us
because i think we want we did that
question
really time and i got a bunch of answers
or anything it was a long time ago
there is some biological reason i think
part of it has to do with being
horizontal
part of it has to do oh interesting the
temp water temperature
yeah you know that even even when you're
swimming in a 75 degree pool it's still
so much colder than your body so your
body is expending
a large percentage of its resources just
to keep you warm
on top of you know the exercise that
you're doing yeah
i think that the tiredness and the
hunger
and also it's like a delayed thing right
so you're not really thinking about
i mean i don't really get hungry when
i'm swimming usually but then like you
know sometimes i'll be in the shower and
i'll just be like
holy give me a i'm i'm so hungry
you know
but i get freaked out open water
swimming do you well i don't
i don't mind it in tropical locations
where i can see everything
but in the pacific it's so murky and
i don't like not being able to see the
bottom and then your mind
starts to wander oh yeah in a bad way
you know you're you're part of this food
chain you're unbelievably vulnerable
and then it's difficult for me to like
relax and enjoy it
well part of that is definitely the
temperature um do you have
particular moments that you recall as
being
super terrifying in open water um
i mean i will say that when i'm with
other people it's fine but sometimes i
want to just go by myself but i'm
reluctant to do that i just don't feel
like that's
a responsible thing to do so i've done
it but then i'm nervous because i'm
alone and no one quite knows where i am
right yeah one of the things about open
water swimming
in the time of covid was i i kept
telling myself that
you have to be more conservative than
you might be otherwise because you don't
want anyone to have to
save you and i got freaked out when i
did the alcatraz swims a very long time
ago
my buddies and i did it without a
wetsuit um
because we were you know 25 or whatever
and it's like you're a puss if you wear
a wetsuit so we
we did it without wetsuits and i just
remember
being halfway i mean it's not that far
what is it like a kilometer and a half
or something like that
it's like a what is it a mile and a half
yeah um being in the middle like perhaps
like smack in the middle
and i just stopped for a moment and
looked around and i was like i'm in a
shipping channel like that freaked me
out because there's
massive boats they come and they're so
it wasn't the marine life it was like
the fact that like there's
gigantic cargo ships right that pass
through there
um but my hands and my feet got so numb
they just felt like
nubs you're like doing this the fist
swimming
i didn't do that again without a wetsuit
i um
had a similar experience when i was
doing my alcatraz swim and then i
hit a patch of seaweed and you know when
you hit something when you're swimming
you
you can't stop yourself from doing that
jerk up right
and it was like my heart was like in my
mouth
and then i just was like oh see we see
it too because you're just you can't
you're right you can't see anything
yeah and it's freaky touches you
i'm not i'm not really afraid of char
like if i'm in hawaii and i can see
everything even if i saw
a predatory um fish like
i don't know that it would scare me that
much i've been recently i've been
working uh for the last couple of months
on a story about fear
and that involves a shark um
[Music]
uh involves sharks and uh someone who
spends a lot of time with them and i
was thinking to myself that i have never
sharks haven't been a thing for me
either right it's not something that has
occupied my mind but i also
have have been really intrigued by how
it occupies the imagination of so many
people
who would never encounter sharks they
but but it lives in their imagination
and of course
jaws but also that it um
it's like a convenient receptacle
for your fear right so it personifies
whatever fear
that you have yeah and actually
it just is a way for you to um
deal with it like it's it's all of these
other things
um and when we were just talking earlier
about the
you know being in the dark deep ocean
and the sharks like that being the
the most profound fear or the scariest
place in any primal thing
and it is yes do you know this guy
michael muller this photographer
who's done all these um
photo essays on great whites and he
swims outside of the cage and
it's incredible he's on the podcast and
now he's creating this virtual reality
oh really series where you put on the
goggles and you know basically you're
swimming with great whites
outside of a cage have you tried it um
he
let me test it in the middle of the
podcast we took a break and i put him on
and checked it out it's it's
wild right but they're using this now in
kind of a um oh like a fear conditioning
exactly
yeah yeah to work with people who have
ptsd and
you know other kinds of fears to help
help them like process all of that in a
healthy way
yeah i think that that fear exposure
or exposure therapy is really
interesting um and i and i
think it's fascinating how vr can
help with that um and i'm really curious
about how the technology you know
because the
so much of the earlier iterations of it
have made people so nauseous like
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think there's
they're still working that out i got a
little bit like that
you know i think i would have then
develop a
a fear of nausea but but it's um
i think i don't know how you could
possibly solve for that problem though
because your body
your inner ear is just doing whatever i
don't think that you how do you correct
that you know
how do you i don't know solve the
disconnect i mean
yeah i don't know i don't know the
answer to that you can talk to michael
yeah i'll hook you up you should
interview him um when you
look at kim or people like lynn cox or
louis pugh or martin stroud like these
epic
you know super long distance swimmers
louis like swam in the arctic circle
right
and didn't martin swim the amazon he
slammed
amazon he did like a ridiculous amount
of butterfly too didn't he did you do
you
yes which i think is hilarious how is
that he's like he swam the whole amazon
river butterfly i'm like that's not
humanly possible he seems like a
freaky guy it can't be the butterfly
what's your form like
i would like to see that it's still
crazy impressive i can't imagine
i like what is it that these people
share
um definitely a high pain threshold
uh i think there's def i uh what i um
what i have gleaned from talking to
some of these incredible
endurance swimmers is that they they
they are different
they're definitely different from us or
maybe not from you you're you're an
endurance athlete
i don't like cold though go ahead i
think cold is a is a
is a divisive thing yeah amongst i mean
us i like it after i've done it and i've
put myself in that system for that
reason but i
i'm not like kim who like can't wait to
get into this right
she just jumps right in um
they're very there's like a certain
single-mindedness i think
um and certainly an ability to
i think disassociate from their bodies
in a lot of ways because their bodies
are
enduring so much not just with the cull
but with the
the length of time and the distance that
they're swimming um
but they seem like they have all kinds
of different reasons for
um that they say that right
it's it's very much about environmental
preservation like he has a big
why you know a big purpose behind why he
does what he does
but he also talked about how before he
started doing that um
i think he was a lawyer wasn't he a
lawyer i think so
um and then just started
um yeah i i think that he
he so wanted to swim he kind of
developed the reasons
reasons to swim over the course of time
but he
was a very driven person so like i i
think that
these athletes
are do start out as very motivated
people
whatever it is kim kim was super
motivated like doing her
you know and her um you know silicon
valley job before
adobe i think so i think that
they have just turned their focus and
vision to something that they can really
go all
in on um in a practice that rewards that
right yeah um and it is very extreme
like i don't i
i am i think i'm having trouble
talking about it because i don't
understand it myself you know even in
the in the competition
part of the book and actually this is
interesting i asked lynn cox and i asked
louis pugh about competition right
because and lynn really
chafed against me um asking her that
question because she said i'm not
competitive i'm not swimming against
anyone else
um and then it kind of she can still be
internally composed
exactly and then actually was she kept
talking she chafed against it because
she didn't see it as
um she she didn't see it as being
externally motivated by what anyone else
was doing i think that was the thing
that she
that rubbed her the wrong way to to
think about but
she you know she she is the she is
concerned with it though like it was
about
being the first and the you know coldest
and the longest
um but it was against herself for sure
i think that uh because once she started
to talk about it it became this
it was clear that she is a
competitive person even though she
didn't necessarily like to think of it
but with kim it all seemed so easy like
she's always laughing and smiling you
know like ain't nothing but the thing
yeah oh but she is like she's got some
shark in her
hair did you talk to ross edgely i
didn't talk to ross edgely ross edgely
um i remember god i remember when he did
what was the last it was uh a year and a
half ago i think when he did the great
british swim
it was the book was done but i remember
reading about that and thinking he would
have been an interesting guy yeah and he
has his own
book he's great yeah yeah he's i mean he
i mean he's
also a force of positive energy like he
just
he really he's he's insanely fit and
like trains like a madman right but he's
always laughing
like it is play i mean this is another
theme of the book like
the relationship between swimming and
play and um kim has that
ross definitely has that like he's a
beast but he's literally
constantly cracking jokes and just you
know lighting up whatever room that he
walks into he's very charismatic in that
regard
and what's interesting about him is he
looks like a bodybuilder yeah he has
unbelievable endurance so he wrote this
book about you know this
um combination of endurance and and
strength and how that works because you
would think like oh you got to be really
lean to be able to do something so long
but he swam all the way around great
britain it was
bananas and he crazy he documented the
whole thing along the way like he had
the rashes on his neck i remember
reading about it
you just got like open so like beaten by
when he's doing this and he came out and
did the podcast like right afterwards
like he literally had just
did you see his scars he was putting
you know that heavy heavy duct tape on
it and all kinds of stuff
um but he's somebody who you know grew
up as a waterfall player
was kind of a competitive swimmer but
not at an elite level or anything like
that
and just comes up with these events to
do so he's internally
competitive he's competitive with
himself and he's battling the elements
but it's not about
there's never anyone else that he's
competing against other than himself
right and and the elements
yeah i think that you um to do all these
things you you have to have some
motivation that is
just very consuming you know whether
it's externally motivated or internally
it's just
it is and and i think that you because
you've had conversations with
all kinds of people who are pushed to do
extraordinary things i'm sure that the
sort of like outset
you know what you know whether it's
something that they were always striving
for approval from someone
or that they always just wanted to um
know that they were capable of something
more um than what everyone told them
that they could do
um or whether it's for some you know i
wanna raise awareness about something
but it is like
there is how do we talk about it is
important
um i suppose that it's not necessarily
it doesn't necessarily matter what it
what the specific thing is but there's
got to be some
force that is compelling us to do it
right
i loved the backtracking into the
history
of of swimming and in particular
competitive swimming
tracing it back to its roots all the way
to
ben franklin inventing the hand paddles
which was like
that just blew my mind i can't stop
thinking about that
i mean he he is the true renaissance man
yeah of course of course he invented
hand paddles
you know it's unbelievable um and that
cave in the
sahara where oh yeah it was basically a
tomb right where there were
drawings of people swimming in a pond
when at one time very long ago
the sahara was a lush green the green
side main
it was dotted with paleo lakes you know
um i love that story i love that um the
you know the first human record of
swimming is in the middle of the desert
in africa because of course it is um
but that you look at these images and it
really looks like people are
just breast breast stroking up the walls
and um i also love that
the the hungarian explorer
who discovered that cave at the time
los alamos he wrote a book about it
and he speculated that
there were actual lakes and bodies of
water around
the cave at the time that the drawings
were made and of course
the theory of climate change then was
just
outrageous and so radical and he was
like his
um his editor reportedly was so like
upset about that that
he put a footnote that said i don't
subscribe to this like harebrained idea
of
that at one time there was water right
but of course he was right
yeah um but at that time it was pretty
radical and
um now of course there's so much
evidence about
about the green sahara and that there
are
you know hippo bones tortoise shells
like um fish you know
you know mittens of clam shells like
it's just
amazing to think about yeah it's crazy
yeah and to think that
humans relationship with water dates
back
to the inception of mankind yeah and and
certainly
before any re you know this is this is
probably dates back up to 10 000 years
ago but
we likely knew how to swim way before
that it's just that there's no
there's no trace of evidence yeah um
let's talk about the samurais okay and
the
this is something else i had no idea
about which is super cool
um so there is
of course there is a swimming martial
art in japan so
nihonejo is the term for it in japanese
it's the japanese
classical swimming art so
much like judo or kendo there is there's
the practice
and it originated with the samurai
during the feudal period of japan and
think about all these parts of the land
that had to be protected by these
different samurai clan
clans and because
of japan being archipelago and there's
different
you know there could be on the ocean or
it could be on the edge of a lake or a
river
the clans each developed their own
schools of swimming so they had
different techniques for how to protect
uh their you know the the land that they
were protecting
and um there are these one of my
favorite tidbits is that the
sort of egg beater technique um of
synchronized swimming
has its has been described in
samurai scrolls like hundreds of years
old
and if you think about some of the
things that they
taught in these uh schools of swimming
they're called ryu i'm not pronouncing
it right r-y-u
um that uh you know you would learn how
to cut through breaking waves with your
arms like in a parallel fashion or that
you would learn to approach
in a very calm lake you know submerged
like most of your body submerged and you
would learn to leap up
out of the water into a boat there's a
there's a move called the flying mullet
you can also google this
yeah on youtube but this is from a
warrior culture like this is how you
you use water to your advantage exactly
so it is
much in the same way that now martial
arts
you know they are practice right they
are a physical but also a psychological
practice a philosophical practice a
whole body
practice and mind and i love
i loved learning about nihon neho
because
it it was a different way to think about
swimming outside of this western idea of
competition and racing um
and it is fascinating because uh
you know nihone has still practiced in
japan
today and there and i went to japan to
research this and you know in the tokyo
olympics they were supposed to have an
ex
exhibition of oh wow yeah
i spoke with the um a lot of these
masters of different schools of nihon
neho who
i um were preparing this exhibition
to kind of reintroduce to the world and
perhaps introduce
for the first time what the sort of
foundation of
um japanese
swimming not you know the national team
success that we know it today
so much of it breaststroke right so like
they've been japanese swimmers have been
really dominant in breaststroke for a
long time
and there is an interesting historical
link to
the techniques of nihon ejo i mean i
remember talking to
one of these masters of of the the art
and
and he was trying to explain and we were
we were observing a class
um in yokohama of of these swimmers um
taking this the class and he said you
know
he was we were observing the glide and
the certain formations that they would
be swimming in
and he said you know you know kitajima
you know kosuke kitajima which is like
the
the world record holder yeah right just
this
dominant breaststroker known
for like this incredible glide
and he said that's nice like that's
the skill that we teach and that has
been ingrained into
like coaching um yeah it's
it's fascinating um to
track that uh you know the antecedent of
japanese swimming success back to that
practice and i didn't
know that the japanese were so dominant
at the end of the 1920s like the
1934 olympics they won like 12 medals or
something like that i had no idea that
they like blasted onto the scene yeah
that was crazy and it's all rooted in
this practice
which my sense is
it's not quite a tai chi thing but maybe
where they might share some sensibility
is this idea of
learning how to use learning how to work
with the water like being symbiotic with
the water and using it to your advantage
like we all know the swimmer who isn't
so experienced and
they're in a race or in a triathlon or
something like that and they're they're
they're fighting the water
it's obvious they're they're making the
water work against them you know what i
mean
and and really you know swimming is
about fitness of course
and technique but it's really about
finesse and it's it's this
um delicate relationship
and this touch and this feel that you
develop over time and some have an
innate talent for
where they just know how to flow with
the water and make it work for them and
those tend to be the most successful
swimmers
i think that the tai chi um analogy is
really
silly in this in this context i mean it
is about
um working with the element
and figuring out how to
use it to your advantage and be really
efficient
too i think that's something that um
people don't really think about with
swimming and they think that
it's like you said when when there's
when people are starting to swim
are starting to learn how to swim
competitively and go
fast like there's so much muscling
there's so much over
like windmilling you know you're just
trying to like overpower it with brute
force and really it's about like your
timing your angle of entry
your the position of your body in the
water and if you have that
it's actually quite you're not expending
a lot of energy right
um one of the things that's interesting
about lynne cox is that
her buoyancy is such a in in salt water
she's like neutrally buoyant so she's in
that perfect
um body position to be swimming
for hours and hours and hours and miles
and miles and miles because she has that
she's riding a little bit higher than
the average person would you know and
she's talked about that
and um so that also helps her
you know with her very very long swims
um
but it's also about touch and finesse
like you said yeah for sure
and in this practice they have much like
karate like you get
lines on your cap or whatever yeah each
like level that you
achieve like stripes in some cases um
because i asked them i said how do you
know who's the master and they said look
at the caps and and they all have their
special caps
and i it was so cool to learn about it
um and i i hope to
get the opportunity i actually had been
trying and planning to get to the tokyo
olympics so i could
see that you know happen um see that
sort of reintroduction of
um to the world but what's your sense of
whether the olympics
are going to happen or not oh my gosh
well can they make a bubble big enough i
don't know
right what do you think yeah i don't i
don't know i don't know
i don't know it's changing so quickly i
mean the spikes that we're seeing right
now
make me feel pessimistic about it but
yeah we'll have to see but at some point
they have to make a decision there's so
many moving pieces and so much money at
stake they can't just snap their fingers
right beforehand and say it's happening
or it's not like at what point
do you pass that point of no return in
terms of the green light or the red
light well now we're getting
and then we'll be getting into the point
where then it is in the same year as the
winter olympic year right again which is
kind of ironic i know
can you imagine being an olympic athlete
and living in that space of not knowing
yeah it's like a
state of suspended animation and i think
it's so
i so feel for those athletes who are
not knowing you know they're trained and
then they have had to calibrate their
training for
another year and i think it will like
break a lot of people
if if it doesn't happen i mean it'll
play to the advantage of the younger
less experienced athlete i suppose who
who who
benefits with additional time but
there's so many people that are hanging
on and
trying to make ends meet while they do
it right and
without that certainty it's probably
really difficult to get
sponsor support right it's just got to
be really challenging
it turns out it's expensive yeah to be
an
it is right it's expensive to live
um another idea that i really love about
the book is this idea
that to be a swimmer is to be a seeker
on some level and and when you track
through history
there are so many leaders and great
thinkers
who had this profound relationship with
the water from
thoreau to lord byron and you know even
jfk like people
who would gravitate towards the water
in times of crisis or as a daily
practice
to basically help them be more
self-actualized better human beings
right um i love that fdr
was the one who put the pool in right
you know fdr put the pool in the white
house
and it lives under the white house press
pool briefing room which is just
is that what it cannot get better than
that i don't actually no i've never
quite been able to pinpoint if that's
why
but um i recently had um
yeah i recently was talking about this
with someone
and um you know one of the reporters at
npr who who goes the
who reports in the white house said yes
you can see the tile
so you'd be in the room so it's
underneath the room but you can still
see
the tile and like where um
where the pool actually is is a is a
bunch of like internet servers and stuff
and i thought that is oh and that
hillary clinton
wanted when they moved into the white
house she wanted to reopen the pool
again
yeah as a pool somehow that didn't
happen but
um i thought wow that would have been
great right
well i know jfk swam
a lot and in particular it was very
helpful
when he was in the middle of the cuban
missile crisis yeah to try to like
get some distance and and balance so he
could solve this unsolvable problem
isn't it fun to think about swimming as
like a a hidden actor
in on these moments of history maybe
that's a good one
well and imagine being fdr the freedom
you know
of being able to get out of the
wheelchair and move your phone and that
he hid
his yeah nobody knew you know yeah his
he hit his it was so hard
um and then it finally became you know
uh
impossible to hide um his physical
you know limitations right so how do you
think about that
relationship between being a seeker and
being in the water um
well i i i mean i certainly think it's
true for myself
um one of the i i wrote
my first book um american chinatown
about
how i noticed that when i would go to a
city i would
the first the first thing i'd do i
looked to see if
i had chinatown and i would go and kind
of see it was interesting
it was just a little window to see
how is this place different or the same
um
to me across the chinese diaspora and
then
i realized what i do with swimming is
that i look for a place to swim
yeah a pool or body of water and um
how often is the pool in chinatown oh
well there's the chinatown ymca in san
francisco there you go
gorgeous pool uh but uh
yeah not that often it turns out right
um but i i don't know i think that water
i think water and seeking it
is something that
for me it's about finding freedom it's
about finding a new perspective it's
about finding a new way of looking at
things and
i mean isn't that what being a writer is
so i think for me
it's like these two things are
hand-in-hand um for sure about how my
mind works that way
what's the longest you've gone without
swimming oh
that's a great question um
[Music]
even when i tore my acl many many years
ago
oh god i remember this i had that stupid
machine that like moves your knee at
night ah
and my husband made me sleep on like the
couch because he was like i'm not
sleeping next to that thing
oh god that was like what 15 years ago
um i wasn't out of the water for that
long
but i but it's because it's rehab
it's recovery it's like one of the first
like the only things you could do
when you're you know recovering from
surgery
in many cases right it's interesting
that when people get injured
on land they send them to the pool to
repair themselves right
and then they go back on land and then
pound the crap out of their bodies
yeah i had laird hamilton here the other
day and he's got these
legendary pool workouts you know and
part of the philosophy
behind it is that very thing which is
when you injure yourself and you go to
physio they teach you all these
rudimentary like things and you kind of
do them for a while and then you're
healed and then you stop doing them and
he's like
we should just keep doing them and what
if we do some of the more rigorous
exercises
in the pool where you remove the thing
that's making you injured in the first
place and create this supportive
environment that allows you to
do more with less risk laird hamilton is
basically saying what every physical
therapist
is like yelling at their at their
patient and saying just
keep doing it why don't you keep doing
it my brother's pt
oh yes i hear him right so lamenting all
the time like
and he says to me because i said my my
elbow and my shoulder were
of bothering me the other day he said so
did you stop doing the exercises
that i gave you and i said i did i could
go back and swim so that was in the past
so then i stopped of course right
um let's talk about this guy in iraq
uh iraq who is who is teaching swimming
lessons
because this is another cool story i
don't know anything about this guy well
a foreign service yeah dude jay taylor
um this is another story actually this
uh section of the book came he was also
another pen pal of mine
but he was a pen pal like many like a
long time ago
he had read something that i'd written
for the new york times about um
swimming as the last refuge from
connectivity and he said you know
i have a story for you about how it
brought people together
and it was about community about
connection and um
he was this foreign service guy who got
sent to a rock
for a posting for a couple of years i
think it was 2008 to 2010 and it was a
time when
um baghdad was seeing a lot of a lot of
active like shelling activity and so it
was a pretty
hairy time to be there and he was in the
green zone which at the time was part
was in situated in saddam hussein's
republican palace now i don't know if
you know this but
saddam hussein and his sons were very
fond of swimming
and so at all of their palaces and homes
around iraq they had these
crazy pools like just again like
luxury upon luxury in the desert is like
having a pool
that you keep filled and um
this pool had multi-level diving boards
in fact you can see
um there are some i don't know if
they're still up but there are some
youtube videos of uh service
soldiers yeah soldiers like jumping off
of the diving boards
um which doesn't actually it doesn't
see watching them doesn't speak well of
us i don't know there's just something
we
it's that kind of like imperialist um
view that has so gotten us into trouble
but anyway so
um but in this time of war of course
there is a community
that forms around this pool because of
course everyone is drawn to this
at that pool yeah and suddenly they're
like wait we're allowed to use this pool
it is like
got fountains and tiles and diving
boards and it just is
glorious and again it's peace it's
finding quiet
and he said that when he um
would get in this pool he would just
then that's when he stopped hearing like
the firing range
you know you'd be muffled and otherwise
it's like this incessant noise of like
military exercises and
um you know they're the the people who
were
there were from all over the world you
know they're
diplomats soldiers u.n peacekeepers
translators local iraqis who were you
know there providing support
and he saw that
that pool was again like everyone all
the animals flock to the watering hole
right
but this in this case it was like a
psychological
space like a coping mechanism coping
mechanism and
um he was swimming
he he taught swimming lessons for a long
time he was a
lifeguard you know had grown up in the
baltimore suburbs i think
dc and he
he has you know great form and he
started to teach let people come up to
him say hey you got any
tips for me and he would see his
colleagues flailing around in the pool
and he would offer some tips and he's a
very like when you read the book you
understand that he's just like a very
kind he's a teacher he's like
he's his his joy and his role in life is
to be a teacher
you know he's a very and to do it and
and
and you've you've encountered many
coaches over your life
as i and the best coach is one
who kind of instills a little bit of
fear
but all but but that but that you want
you it's authority you seek that
approval
you seek that approval i wouldn't say
that he's a person oh i don't know what
what he is like as a parent but um he's
a very gentle
guy at this point in his life but you
see that he has this quiet authority
that you
want to you know that he knows things
and you want him to
share them with him and so he was able
to kind of
i mean i think of him as a pied piper of
all of these swimmers
in in the green zone because he kind of
was
he ended up building this you know
baghdad swim club of like a roster of
250 somewhat people rotated over
two years uh and would be teaching
swimming less i mean they they kept
having to add
classes because they kept coming
together it's like a feel-good movie
yeah it's totally a feel-good movie jay
taylor folks you can contact me
for the rights with him
i didn't realize what really struck me
aside from that story is
this discussion around um
you know how beautiful the sunsets are
and like how people would swim
like sort of a dusk or a dawn like not
not at high noon it was too hot
but when the sand would kick up that's
when you would get the really epic
sunsets but that was also the danger
signal because that's when the incoming
mortars
occur right because that sand would
obscure
the ability to find the people who'd
been hit right
right you it was cover
for um it was a good mortaring
opportunity
and it's just like to exist in that
reality like you're in this you have
this pool with fountains but
right outside of it like people are
getting shelled yeah
um and you know he
jay almost got hit by a mortar um
in his trailer like on the third day he
was in baghdad you know he
he really almost didn't live to um
[Music]
have this club you know teach these
people to swim and it is
it sort of underlines this
just how again poorestness between
states and one that's one of the big
themes of the book is like
we're i think with swimming
what's so intriguing to me about it is
that it is a sport it is a practice it
is
something we do for exercise but it is
it is
it is the difference between life and
death and water
that is the reality i mean that is crazy
and
we don't we don't dance very often
it's that close these days to death i
mean
last year this past year is has been
an exceptional year to that but in our
modern day we don't experience that
acute acuteness
most of us don't anyway um most of us
are lucky not to
and so i think sports of course
competition is a way to experience this
acuteness of being right this
um the adrenaline rush
the um the
urgency of feeling just really alive
and and oftentimes that
you know that feeling
is something that we we kind of can only
really approximate
um with something that's a very
heightened experience
right but swimming allows you to
practice literally putting yourself in
an unnatural
environment yeah one that can really
again
and certainly especially with the ocean
can really rob you
of that life in pretty short order if
you're not careful
i don't want to scare people but no but
it isn't i don't think about that yeah
like i
you know that doesn't occur i'm so
acclimated to swimming like
pool forget about it like i don't think
of a pool being dangerous at all like
it's just that is my natural habitat
right i'm more hyper aware of that when
i'm in the ocean of course but
right but you were talking about how you
don't like it yeah i know i mean that's
definitely a thing but but like in the
pool like the idea that
that something bad is going to happen to
me is not anything that i think about
yeah
yeah but that is a very real thing for a
lot of people right
i mean and i think that's super
interesting and i wanted
this book to
explore that with that reader i wanted
to
acknowledge that reality that that fear
is real like so the people who
don't like swimming who are afraid of
the water that is
very that is a profound fear and that is
is something that
once you get to you know to become
an adult to be a certain age where you
feel that that door is completely closed
to you
because that fear is so profound and
it's so
um primal and it is something that
you have to be brave to actually
push past that and and say i want to
learn how to swim
yeah and i've talked to quite a few
folks who
um you know had recently started to
take lessons or had um
uh started to try to
address their you know their their fears
and their lack of swimming ability
um over the over the course of the last
couple of years and
it's you know it is very much tied to
like some bad experiences they've had
maybe when they were kids um
but also there's there's just a lot of
emo there's a lot of bags well you're
very vulnerable you're essentially naked
yeah you know and you're putting
yourself in this environment where you
can't breathe
yeah your whole life you've like said
talk to the hand
you know so it is it is courageous yeah
it's doable
if you submit to the process yeah you
know you're
it is a weird thing it's like violin or
you know anything else like if you don't
learn it when you're a young kid it's a
lot harder when you're older but that
doesn't mean that you can't do it
um and i know plenty of people who
learned later in life and just
love it yeah now and it does serve
you know everybody has their own
relationship with it i know that your
relationship with it has changed over
time as has mine but
what will always remain consistent is
this
you know flow-like experience that you
have in water that i
i can't replicate in any other way yeah
you cite uh
like moby dick in that right like this
idea of sea dreaming like
like meditation and water are wetted
forever which is a line out of that book
yeah it keeps me going
yeah it is meditation it is and it isn't
it's a specific type of meditation it's
moving meditation
i think that's actually
someone had told me um recently that
they stopped doing yoga once they
discovered swimming
really because it did serve them for
them function for them yeah
yeah yeah i'm not surprised but you know
what it's better when you do both
they're different they are different
they are different and
and surfing is a whole different thing
right which is another
aspect of swimming i suppose on some
level but yeah
its own unique relationship with water
and and
symbiotically living with the elements
and timing i mean i
i thought about that this morning um
when i got out was just
you have to but it's the same principle
of
you have to time it right you have to
read the water right and then you have
to move
in just the right way to get on the way
otherwise it's not pretty yeah
so i suppose you're gonna swim for the
rest of your life i hope so
they better open the pools back up soon
yeah
right yeah i know a lot of
um mer people out of water these days
they're just they're not the same don't
you feel
more just i feel like when i get in
water
in the morning i'm just a better person
i just feel like it's all
back way way better i'm way more capable
and when i said they better open the
pool soon
let me please like couch that contacts
like i'm not saying be
unsafe i just wish we could be in a
situation where it was where pools could
safely open
yeah um because i know that i'm a better
person and
i enjoy it and i and i miss it yeah i
know you do too
what do you let's close it with this
thought which is
what is it that you you know want people
to walk away from
after reading the book
i think it's a sense of possibility
right um i just think about water
these days and i've given this a lot of
thought lately
um especially because i can't
do it i can't do it as readily as i once
could and take it for and i took it for
granted too like anyone else right
um that i could get in the water
whenever i wanted to and find that piece
find that
you know smoothing back of feathers and
that time with myself and now it's like
this juggling act of trying to find
again like the lane reservation or the
window where like i don't have to manage
all
you know stuff at home with my kids and
work and whatever
and my husband who only supports me by
the way
getting out in the water he's just like
go please go go please go
we'll all be happy does he swim he
is he's a pretty good swimmer he
enjoys the water he hates the cold he's
like you he
will not get in the cold water i mean
we woke up the other morning and it was
it was like you know one of those
mornings
that where you could see your breath and
that's not that usual here in california
guys
it's many times a year though i mean
it's high 30s at night here but then
it'll be
82 by like two in the afternoon so we
got up and it was before dark and i was
getting up to go surf and he looks at me
and goes
boy what i really want to do right now
is
jump in the freezing ocean
i i just uh had to laugh because i said
you know that actually i mean i know
that sounds insane but it sounds
pretty good to me and that's why i'm
leaving i love you goodbye
that's hilarious you know and so he
understands me uh-huh
for sure it took me a long time to come
back to that kind of appreciation though
because i was so steeped in competitive
swimming for so long and the idea of the
early morning alarm clock
you know and then standing on the
freezing cold deck in the dark
and i was like i do not need this in my
life anymore i did that for many years
you know but i've kind of come around
to you know fall in love with it in a
new way as long as i don't look at the
pace clock
because that will give you ptsd that is
going to do it yeah
yeah i think it is interesting and i
love to hear you talk about how
you had you had to come around full
circle from
from what was a very intense
and formative experience in your life
you know which is to compete
at a collegiate level and a very
competitive
and very gratifying and one of the
highlights of my life but also
extremely difficult and not without its
traumas right you know and like i needed
to do other things
so there was a long period of time where
i didn't want anything to do with the
swing
yeah i mean you have to have enough
distance from it and also to understand
that
yeah like you're at a different stage of
your life and i think
you know i i like to think about how i
came back to swimming as well like i
there were times when i wasn't as
present in my life and and now
it's gonna come roaring back yeah um in
a very wonderful and real way
do you have a sense that you're more
creative when you're
swimming consistently like you're you're
more in touch with your creative voice
i think so i mean and again like it was
not something that i
thought about until i wrote this book
like i
did not you know examine or interrogate
why
i wanted to get in the water and then
would go and sit and write but
unconsciously you were
you would not have been good right
you're right yeah been interested in
exploring that
it kind of nudged me that way yeah
well thank you thank you for talking to
me today i love the book
um please go check it out it's called
why we swim
it's a very direct title and it
it answers that question um i really
loved it and i'm so
happy that the book is being so well
received and so successful
i know you've got another book right
about uh it's like a children's book
about
a woman big wave surfer it's um
it's sarah and the big wave and it's
about
sarah gerhart the first woman to serve
mavericks yeah
she the one that's in riding giants
she's
um in the mavericks segment oh she
probably was one woman that's
interviewed
around the mavericks discussion in that
movie i mean
so long since i've seen that documentary
but um yeah it was
i mean she 1999. and she's in she lives
in santa cruz
she's a you know she's a professor you
know it's it's
like it's so she's a it's a wonderful
story
um and and it was my first
children's book and it was such a joy to
write so fun
how did you find like do you i assume
you got an illustrator to work with
um sophie dale she
they asked my publisher actually asked
me like they don't normally do it so in
publishing
i only just found this out when i
encountered this it was
um usually children's books you think
that the
you know the writer and the and the
illustrator is working together
no it's like usually the writer writes
the book and then they
find an illustrator impaired really yeah
right
because it's all these books seem so how
is that possible like you have to be
sympathetic
exactly but and and usually the
publisher does not consult the author
the publisher just chooses but in this
case they let me choose
and she said yeah don't consult them
they don't do that
it's two lanes it's like um and
and and they have the author and they
have the illustrator
and they do the pairing that's like 90
percent of the time
isn't that fascinating it's shocking to
me i know because it seems like you have
to have it braided together
yeah yeah i mean i guess it works
but i i feel like they they're missing
out on an opportunity is what i'm saying
yeah i think so speaking of which why
didn't you read your audiobook
oh that's a great question um i
i don't know that the option was offered
to me
but they said i'm doing it they asked me
well
again they asked me who i wanted so they
gave me a bunch of
um different professionals
maybe they just thought they needed a
professional
but i thought angie kane she did a great
job
but i just think because you're so much
a part of the narrative yeah
that i would have i would have liked to
have heard you read well thank you
next time next time but it was your foot
down it's your book
now let's throw my weight around type um
cool
well come back and talk to me again
sometime this is really fun
thank you rich um where should i direct
people who want to learn more
about what you're up to what's the best
place you're on twitter and all the
things i'm on twitter and instagram and
all the things
um you can find me on my website
at bonnietoy.com
easiest way to do it do it all right
thanks
thanks let's go swimming let's do it
peace
plants
[Music]
you